[Music]
here with pop culture historian and
author of this book Americana the
beautiful today we're going to be
learning about a very special Easter
tradition from days past please welcome
our good friend Charles Phoenix Charles
great
now trust we first met you introduced us
to these retro slide shows you found
these old colored slides vintage slides
from the 50s and the 60s and you became
kind of obsessed with them yes I've been
collecting other people's old slides for
20 years all right and call me a slide
[ __ ] if you want well I find it more
creepy than anything else
let's see some slides from your Easter
collection they'll be back this is a
what is this the 50s the 60s this is the
1950s and this is a big giant Easter
Bunny so if you have a giant Easter
Bunny fetish this would be the perfect
place for you to go stand in between the
legs well if anyone want to be there or
see that it's horrific looking but I got
some fun this is Americana Conan you
know that was in New Hampshire by the
way okay I've been there yeah that helps
I guess let's check this one out this is
just a weird egg house it is it's at
Santa's Village and I think it's like
mr. Easter Bunny trying to lure Mary and
her little ants in there with a big
giant steak or something I'm not sure
again that's just horrific come into
this weird house let's look at this next
one this is a oh okay
lamb cakes are a very traditional part
of Easter what year is this do you think
this is like 1957 right and this is the
traditional lamb cake right here but
this one is extra special because it
bears a striking resemblance Conan to
the King of Pop decided I wanted to make
the lamb cake I did but you know what
when I got this classic lamb cake in the
mail I decided I was feeling a little
more savory than sweet so I decided my
lamb cake should be meatloaf and the
frosting should be mashed potatoes okay
so that's what we're gonna we're gonna
make a vintage lamb cake out of me
loaves yeah meatloaf version okay Easter
meatloaf of lamb Kona we got to get
started right away first thing you got
your meat right here yeah okay you ever
made a meatloaf before no I don't really
cook made ramen pride noodles okay
crack your egg in there and pour some
breadcrumbs in and the seasoning mix so
it tastes good
okay you got to do that okay I don't
know what I'm doing yes tree it's like
science now the papers going in as well
okay that's okay
okay now what happens do I put the whole
envelope in oh yes yes all of it you
want okay and how many of the
breadcrumbs do I put just about go ahead
go ahead go ahead not too much okay top
go ahead that's too much no you're okay
cheering time sir now what mush it all
together I see mushy mush
don't you love missing meatloaf no not
really at all you don't know you and I
agree on next to nothing as we do
[Applause]